how's it going everybody it's Warren and
Avengers in-game was such an amazing
movie and it was an amazing movie for so
many different reasons it wasn't just
amazing because all of the actions and
the story it was amazing for many
different reasons including all of the
callbacks the references and the Easter
eggs that they threw in the movie and
they certainly did throw in a lot I've
heard some people say that they've
counted over 500 Easter eggs callbacks
and references and Avengers in game and
with so many of them sometimes it's hard
to tell if it was actually an easter egg
or a reference or if it was just part of
the movie however luckily for us after
the movie comes out the directors and
the writers go on tour and do a ton of
interviews in which they confirm many
different Easter eggs and in a recent
interview Marvel has in fact confirmed a
secret Wars Easter egg and Avengers
endgame it's really exciting and I'll
talk about what it could mean for the
future of the MCU in this video but
first a quick reminder about my giveaway
when I hit 450,000 subscribers I will be
picking three winners and each will get
to choose one item from the Marvel
Legends series collection all you have
to do to enter is be subscribed to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain so there
are probably a lot of people that caught
The Secret Wars Easter egg and Avengers
in game right after Professor Hulk snaps
2014 Thanos comes into the present time
and launches an attack on the avengers
headquarters completely destroying it
when Thanos attacks the compound the
building collapses and professor Hulk
holds it up to save war machine and
rocket now many fans wondered if this is
in fact an ode to the Secret Wars comics
it certainly does look like it even
though the Hulk and Avengers in game is
Professor Hulk and they're only two
people below the building that he is
holding up but still fans wondered and
argued for and against it but thanks to
a recent interview we found out that
this is in fact a secret Wars node in a
recent interview Joe Russo was asked if
this scene was a reference to the Secret
Wars comics and he said 100% now Joe
Russo is a huge Secret Wars fan so it
makes sense that he would put this
Easter Egg in Avengers in game but
something that is very interesting is
what Joe and Anthony Russo said before
Avengers endgame can
in an interview with Collider months
before Avengers endgame came out the
Risa Brothers actually did a Q&A about
Avengers infinity war with Collider
where they actually brought up Secret
Wars the Russo brothers had stated that
they're going to be taking a break from
directing Marvel movies after all they
directed Captain America the Winter
Soldier Captain America Civil War
Avengers infinity war and of course
Avengers endgame and Joe Russo said
we've done four of these movies in six
years so we're ready for a little
vacation and asked if he would ever come
back to working with Marvel he said I
love working with Marvel Secret Wars can
bring me back to the MCU so the Russo
brothers said that they would come back
to direct another Marvel film if it was
specifically Secret Wars and you have to
think that it would be a perfect movie
for the recent others to direct with
Marvel a movie where just a ton of
characters are coming together on screen
which is basically what Avengers
infinity war and Avengers end game was
and now Marvel has all of these Fox
characters and not to mention all of the
new characters that they want to
introduce into the MCU as well the x-men
alone have so many characters and then
you throw in the Fantastic Four and the
Avengers and the other heroes and at one
point in time they're going to meet it
will be a long slow build-up just like
Avengers infinity war and Avengers in
game but they have to outdo those films
they have to outdo the first 10 years of
the MCU they have to outdo the infinity
Saga and what better way to do that than
to introduce Secret Wars and the battle
world secret Wars and battle world have
been mentioned a lot lately especially
since the spider-man far from home
trailer literally said the word
multiverse for those of you who do not
know what Secret Wars is it is all about
different universes colliding into one
during secret wars the main universe and
the alternate universes get destroyed
and the earths of these universes
combined into one forming the battle
world and the battle world has different
aspects of different universes on it in
secret wars you have just so many
characters you have the Avengers you
have the Fantastic Four the guardians of
the galaxy the x-men Inhumans just so
many characters and everybody is
thinking that now that Disney now owns
the rights to the Fox characters the
x-men and the Fantastic Four along with
others this has to be what Disney is
going to build up to one day and this is
probably one of the very rare films that
could top Avengers end game you could
have movies like The Avengers verse
is the x-men but you wouldn't have the
build up like you would get for Secret
Wars and what's really interesting is
that it has been said that Marvel moving
forward is probably not going to connect
the MCU like they used to the different
movies will of course exist in the same
universe but they will only kind of
reference other movies now if they're
introducing the multiverse into the MCU
and we're going to explore other
universes this makes sense so they could
have a build up of different stories and
different universes and then boom
collide them for Secret Wars this would
be the ultimate Marvel movie and it
sounds like if Marvel does decide to do
this they already have their directors
Anthony and Joe Russo now obviously this
is just wishful fan thinking nothing has
been said about a build-up for Secret
Wars at all the only thing that we have
is that Avengers in-game Secret Wars
Easter Egg but we know that Marvel loves
the Russo brothers and Avengers infinity
war and Avengers and game were massive
success not to mention Captain America
Civil War and when her soldier are also
fans favorite films as well so the Russo
brothers have done Marvel absolute
justice with their films and we know
that fans want Secret Wars to eventually
happen and the build-up for Secret Wars
could possibly be the only thing that
could outperform Avengers infinity war
and Avengers endgame in the MCU so
everything seems to be set up one day we
could possibly get a Secret Wars in the
MCU especially with the introduction of
different universes but let me know what
you all think would you like to see a
Secret Wars film where we have a ton of
different characters the x-men the
Avengers the Fantastic Four all come
together in one giant event and if
Marvel ever did do a Secret Wars let me
know who you would like to see in it let
me know your thoughts in the comments
down below and again another reminder
about my giveaway at the 450,000
subscriber mark I'll be picking three
winners and each will get to choose one
item from the Marvel Legends series
collection and in a couple short weeks
I'll be starting a Twitter and Instagram
giveaway so if you'd like another chance
to win you can follow me on social media
again let me know what you think
about a secret wars in the MCU and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
Wolf Wolf
congratulations to your desperation to
save the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very nice and
dull it took you said it cost you
everything while crying like a baby now
your